سنبقى مع حفل تتويج الملك ترانز مراسم
الحفل وطريقه ظهور العائله الملكيه ايضا
بروتوكول ملكيه عريق سنتعرف عليه الان
مشاهدينا مع خبير البروتوكول والاتيكيت
غسان حجاج اهلا بك
اهلا قبل القليل كنت اسال
الشعب البريطاني اليوم ليس اغلبيته من
كبار السن اليوم هناك جيل كبير من الشباب
لماذا هذا الاهتمام بكل تقليد عمره نحو
الف سنه
انا شخصيا اتوقع انه كثير من الشباب اليوم
بحسوا انه في نقص من هذه الامور لان كثير
من الاتيكيت اللي هو ورا المراسم
والتشريفات البروتوكول طبعا في اتيكيت
وكثير ناس اليوم ما عندهم ما عندهم خبره
عن هذا الشيء غير عن انه هيدي تعتبر يمكن
اهمها مناسبه بالنسبه للبريطانيين اهم من
اي زواج ملكي
اكيد تتويج يعني هذا اهم شيء فلابد انه
العالم بتحب لانه دائما العائله المالكيه
منحس انه مثل السحر يعني بنحب نعرف كل شيء
بس ما حنعرف كل شيء وما فينا نعرف كل شيء
لهم اسرارهم الخاصه
تكون موجوده بنعرف اكثر
من واقع وحقيقه طيب
بالامس حفله تتويج من ناحيه الاتيكيت
والبروتوكول كيف كان ظهور مشيه افراد
العائله المالكه الملك الملكه كل هذه
الامور كيف طبعا
[موسيقى]
شيء حلو لاحظتو انه هم يهمهم داخلين في
كثير من الرجال طبعا بينزلوا راسهم للملك
وما سووا نفس الحركه
الملكه كاملا ولكن بعد التتويش
عملوها او بالنسبه للسيدات انحاء مثلا
للتاج احتراما للتاج احتراما
متوجه متوجه فعلا وهو طبعا كان يعتبر ملك
من اللحظه اللي توفت فيها جلاله
الملكه
الملوك اللي كانوا حاضرين وجالسين حتى هذا
ماشي على البروتوكول يعني مثلا ملكه
اليونان او ملك بلغاريا كانوا حاطينهم
قدام وليد ولي عهد الدوله مثل الدنمارك او
النرود رغم من الدنمارك والنروج نعتبرهم
بعدهم مملكه ولكن اليونان ليس هي مملكه
اليوم ولكن
لانه اللي كان ملك او ملكه خلاص للحياه
بيبقى في هذا الشيء فبالمراسم في
البروتوكول المنصب
اذا ولدت ملكا تبقى ملكا حتى الموت يعني
هذا الشيء الحلو المميز اللي فيه
وشفنا طبعا العائله حاطينهم على حسب
الرتبه
وشغله كتير حلوه انه
الملك تشارلز
طلب من اخته انه هي تكون من الحراس اللي
بتقول
فهي كانت راكبه على الخيل ورا طبعا العربه
وهم راجعين
انتبهنا انه ما كانت لابسه فستان او هي
الها باع طويل اعتقد ايضا في العسكريه
البريطانيه منعرف باي يعني قسم منها ولكن
هي عسكريه اصلا لانه بداله تلبس فستان
وتياره ومجوهرات كانت لابسه اللبس العسكري
عكس مثلا ابنه الامير هاري اللي هو طبعا
انسحب من الاسره المالكه البروتوكولات
اصلا
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا غسان حج اج خبير
البروتوكولات والاتيكي
ت لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات